[Music]
Neal beg your pardon you must be hella
and for son of Odin really you don't
look like him perhaps we can come to an
arrangement you sound like him kneel
before your queen hey everybody this is
gonna be my non-spoilery thor ragnarok
review they're letting us post it early
because they're pretty confident that
people are gonna love this movie and no
surprise you probably been hearing about
how they sort of reengineered the thor
formula for the Marvel Universe Chris
Hemsworth had been getting tired of
playing the character Anthony Hopkins
actually thought that his character died
after the last movie he's like he's dead
he's not coming back
that's the end of it like he didn't want
to come back to the Thor movies either
so they had to find something new and
fresh to do so if you understand the
Norse concept of Ragnarok that's what
they went to and I think it was the
perfect idea if they got this crazy
weird director Taika Waititi from down
in New Zealand who made this amazing
unabashed love letter to Jack Kirby with
Kevin Feige so if you're a big fan of
the comics especially the Kirby era
comics
this is 100% going to be your favorite
Thor film and probably one of the best
Marvel movies so far and I will rank
this with my other favorite Marvel
movies at the end of the video too but
there is a Thor ticket giveaway going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so just based on the way they
marketed it and based on some of the
comic book stuff that I've read in the
past I had some pretty clear
expectations going into the film
especially given what's happening in
real life with all the actors like okay
people are coming to the ends of their
contracts so they have to make room and
case actors don't want to come back
we're at that point in Marvel phase 3
you've probably seen how other big
movies recently like spider-man Home
Coming are part of phase 3 so they work
as part of this over story building up
to infinity war but they also wind up
feeling more self-contained than phase 1
phase 2 movies so Ragnarok manages to
bring the grandeur that you would expect
from a Thor movie he is a God in the
Marvel Universe an actual God and they
find an interesting way of dealing with
that on a story level but they also
found a lot of
funny ways to take the piss out of the
more ridiculous elements of Thor stories
like you go back and you watch that
first soar film it feels pretty stiff
they played it pretty straight up like
Shakespeare in space like they took it
really seriously so we're at the point
now where there been so many Marvel
movies that they can have a little bit
of fun taking the piss out of themselves
you swear to cast aside all selfish
ambition and to pledge yourself only to
the good of the radio in my seat I would
love for someone else to rule but it
can't be you you're just well without
getting into spoilers they did do a
really good job of leading up to
infinity war and teasing some really big
concepts and some ideas and showing you
just how badass these characters can be
because Hulk Thor even hella are so
powerful that it's just really hard to
show you that when they're with the
other earth-based characters in the
movies so no surprise that Chris
Hemsworth was awesome the thing that's
really changed for him while he's been
playing this character is that people
found out that he's actually a legit
funny person they actually let Chris
Hemsworth be more Chris Hemsworth in
this movie like they let him go full
Hemsworth they went full Goldblum full
Kirby so that all just gets back to the
idea of them doing a story as big as
Ragnarok which is why I think that it
works so all the actors performances
were amazing I mean they got Kate
freaking Blanchette she's probably the
best Marvel villain since Loki and Tom
Hiddleston 2 was one of those characters
who's like you know Willy keep coming
back to the Marvel Universe but he's
also kind of getting tired of playing
that same old character so they just let
the actors have a little bit more fun
especially people like Odin and then you
have people like Benedict Cumberbatch
playing Doctor Strange albeit for a
small portion in the film so I know
you're all wondering about Mark Ruffalo
what's going on with his Hulk he does a
really good job of unleashing a world
breaker Hulk like you've never seen
you've seen him be the hook before but
you've never seen him be a Chatty Hulk
you've never really seen anything but
the mopey version of banner so banner
having more fun and being more in tune
with himself and the big green guy is
just a lot more fun a lot of the things
that I thought about the hella character
coming into the movie ended up being
true
so I'm actually really excited because I
had some big expectations for and there
are a lot of things that we can't talk
about till we get to spoilers but I'm
just so excited for what she's going to
do next
but Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie ends up
being a much better female companion to
Thor than the previous females that were
around him at the other Thor movies no
knock on Natalie Portman or SIF
they serve their roles appropriately but
I'd be like those characters which
weren't written to be quite as fun as
somebody like Valkyrie so there's this
really amazing thing that happens with
the women in the movie like they're all
totally badass but you are at both times
scared and attracted to them obviously
hella is off the chart
Valkyrie is a function of that - can't
say enough about tyka playing Cork he
steals every scene that he's in he's a
bigger part of the movie than I expected
but he's still a relatively minor
character he's playing this crazy
gladiator war bound Hulk character from
the comics with a Maori accent that's so
soft-spoken that if you're not prepared
for it is a bit of a surprise but he
actually said that he's parodying a lot
of the big bouncers back in New Zealand
back in his hometown he said that the
most soft-spoken
nice terrifying people that he's ever
met the most massive dudes that will
just rip your arms out of their sockets
and speak incredibly softly while
they're doing it
but if there was anything that I was
worried about going into the film it was
Jeff Goldblum going full Goldblum I just
didn't know how that would work in a
Marvel movie even though there are a lot
of ridiculous things in Marvel movies so
you're kind of prepared for that but
when you see somebody like Jeff Goldblum
who's known for being ridiculous in that
way you just don't know what you're
going to get and he actually ended up
being pretty good as one of the elders
of the universe but we're not really
talking about Independence Day to Jeff
Goldblum we're talking more about
Jurassic Park Jeff Goldblum he can turn
in some amazing performances if given
the right material and they actually
wound up letting him improvise a lot of
his lines and even though the movie had
a pretty good script they actually wound
up letting a lot of the actors improvise
scenes when it was appropriate so I feel
like more of the comedy elements end up
being improvised in the mythology
elements those tend to be a little more
written out because they're a little
more dense like they have to explain
some
really big concepts and explain some big
aspects of the characters but they let
them try a bunch of different things
with the jokes and I feel like that
ended up working so controlled
improvisation Anthony Hopkins is always
amazing you watch him in shows like West
world you watch his classic films it's
been a long time since I've seen him
turn in a bad performance so they did
have a lot of fun making the movie
you've probably seen some of the
behind-the-scenes featurettes but
generally there were really only a
couple things that disappointed me and
that was mostly because of my
expectations and the lead-up to infinity
war happening so we can talk more about
some of the specific things when we get
to spoilers because I think coming out
of this the most interesting
conversations that people will have are
super spoilery so we'll just have to
wait a little while to do that till
everybody gets a chance to see it but
once you do get a chance to see it let
me know in the comments what you thought
of it compared to the other Thor movies
and then compared to the other Marvel
movies in general because after this I
still feel like Winter Soldier is a
better movie but this is for sure 100%
the best Thor movie to date and they do
a good way of setting up a new Thor
franchise if the actors all want to come
back but it also works as a bookend for
the characters in case they don't which
is a weird thing that they do with the
Marvel trilogies they had to do the same
thing with Iron Man 3
if Robert Downey jr. hadn't have gone
back and renewed his contract through
the Avengers films after Iron Man 3 that
would have been the last time you would
have seen the character so this movie
does the same thing for the Thor
characters including Thor himself but I
do think that because of the way things
went while they were filming it how the
actors feel about and the way they're
talking about it that they will come
back not everybody but I do think that
Thor will be around for a long time in
the Marvel Universe so on my list of
favorite Marvel movies you know favorite
phase 3 movies I'm still expecting
infinity war to probably be my favorite
and I think that black panther just
because it's so fresh and new will be
better received it'll be a slightly
better film overall but I guess that
would make this my number 4 favorite
Marvel movie considering those movies
that have not come yet will probably
rank a little bit higher in my top 5
list but that's another good question
let me know what is your favorite Marvel
movies so far in the comments below and
I'll say congratulation
to the latest giveaway winner Steve
hefferman please private message me so I
can get your contact details there was a
Punisher trailer that just dropped so
I'll do a video for that next we got
some arrow tonight but you can click
here to rewatch black panther while you
wait for that and you can click here to
watch arrow name-drop Batman thank you
so much for watching everybody to stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you